how are we completely missing
this
just the pure
perfection
of this
the childlike awe
and wonder and bliss
and innocence and peace
and play
simply this
the main culprit is time
what is 2 0 2
1
4 symbols
completely irrelevant
you could make four alternative
squiggly lines and put them next to each
other
and as long as we as a collective
hallucinate
that that is the year that it is
then that would simply be that year
recognize the anchor
that is time that is holding you back
from realizing
non-duality
this one is just so salient it's
plastered
all over our culture all the time
there's a clock
on your phone there's a clock on your
computer
there's a clock that's in your living
room there's a clock that's on your
stove
there's a calendar that you use that has
little time slots and little dates that
are completely
arbitrary monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturday sunday
are completely arbitrary symbols that we
use to describe
the quote days in a quote
week which are again completely
arbitrary
even though the earth spins on its axis
and we go
that's a day and it makes one orbit
around the sun
that's a year
this is to say that
they do have use it is useful
to schedule a three o'clock meeting with
somebody and be there at that specific
time
they have use but our culture
is absolutely indoctrinated into
thinking that
they are real when they are an illusion
this is the problem which again in
non-duality there are no problems it is
all perfect
but this is the biggest anchor holding
people back from realizing
nonduality realizing the diamond
necklace that is already around their
neck
realizing simply this
happening now and the perfection
and the childlike innocence and bliss
and wonder and peace
and play in this now
so recognize that this now can be
colored with all different types of
symbols that then make it have
meaning
so you can throw any other four symbols
together
z q p b ah that means this year and then
z q p c is the next year
and that's when you start getting it
that's when you're like okay
i see how absolutely irrelevant and
arbitrary and illusory time is
and then you recognize that that's very
similar about your biological
quote finitude i i am born and i die
no again a big illusion
you are eternal this is eternal
the formlessness continues to appear
eternally
assuming all different appearances of
forms
with appearances of names
so as you with
withdraw yourself more and more from
the layers of identity
that you have with your egoic separate
sugar cube it dissolves
more and more into the oceanic
non-duality
all of what we're doing right now is
we're using language
language in itself is just communication
vibration
it's just the vibration that is coming
out
of me and into
you through this medium
and then there's another language
which is mandarin
if they haven't studied english then
they don't understand these
communication vibrations
since we haven't studied mandarin then
we don't understand their communication
vibrations
so once you begin also identifying
that language in itself is also simply
different communication vibrations and
that
we are just using those communication
vibrations to
quote communicate with one another
because again we want to meet with
somebody at three o'clock
okay got it but when you recognize that
you could easily
just be going like
and that that in itself is also
a communication vibration
and then all you need is somebody else
on the other side of that
that understands what meaning that means
and they get that and they communicate
back to you
in that language
and that's why you have things like you
have the sign languages
as well right you have that
and that should be a big hint is if you
can
use this gesticulation language
that's not even vibratory
that that's a massive hint as well
at the quote
the illusion of all of these quote
descriptors
that describe
what this dream is and we use
these languages whether they're
vibratory or they're gesticulatory
and so once you begin also getting that
in a sense
a good amount of silence also
just lands
quantum mechanics is in itself such a
profound revelation
all is no thing slash
energy
einstein and so many of the greats there
is no matter
it's energy
formlessness appearing
formlessness appearing
formlessness appearing
and everything being energetic also
gives us
deep insight into the
the expression that this
formlessness expresses
energetically when this formlessness
expresses
the truth of the absolute highest
morality of that love
and that bliss and that play and that
peace
and that unity what ends up happening is
that butterfly effect out energetically
whereas
when there's a egoic separate entity
butterflying effecting out negativity
malevolence greed conspicuous
consumption
so life is both
an illusion a dream
and formlessness appearing
it's also beautiful it's also perfect
it's unconditionally free and it's
unconditionally
love
it's absolutely anarchic
there's no determination
and this is what the seeker hates
the seeker hates hearing things like
that there's nothing to seek because
it's already absolutely perfect
and with true simultaneity
that is both true as well as
if you are an egoic contracted separate
entity that is suffering
there is the path that enables that
sugar cube to dissolve into non-duality
you can call that self-realization god
realization
recognizing one infinite creator
recognizing eternity recognizing the
absolute recognizing formlessness
becoming more and more agentless
even transcending the experiencer
the i am and the self becoming more and
more agentless
and attributeless
and this is why it's called an eternal
fireworks
the more that we
surf the crest of that eternal
presence simply now
the more we see it and experience it as
a fireworks we see it and experience it
as a dream as an illusion but it's as a
beautiful fireworks
the beauty in the mic the beauty in the
camera
the beauty in the audience
the beauty in the message
the beauty in the oxygen the beauty in
our heartbeats
the beauty in the food on the table the
beauty in the water that we drink the
beauty
in the shelter over our head
its formlessness appearing
we recognize that and we recognize
the beauty of that eternal fireworks
that's again more true simultaneity
that true simultaneity is a
massive key at the pinnacle of
the mountain top
you can watch that episode on true
simultaneity that
we just published on our channel as well
so melt your world down to the wind
the very wind itself
is the essence of the nature of reality
melt your world down to the wind
surrender to the effortless action
to the way surrender
to that perfection
ask yourself what
at this moment is lacking
what at this moment is
lacking
it's not possible
it's nothing that could be lacking
right now
something that's whole something that's
perfect something that's already
completely free and unconditionally love
cannot have anything lacking
recognize that you are that
i am that we are that that is
us we are it
how many more of the perennial wisdoms
across the spiritual mystic traditions
point have to point to the exact same
thing colored differently
the dao
brahman
god source
infinity one infinite creator
non-duality
the universe the multiverse
the universal wave function
how many more ways do we have to
describe
the same one end
explained in different colors
different paths different faces of the
mountain
we're just completely missing the simple
now the simple this and the truth
that is in the this the simplicity of it
and seekers and scientists
and ego hates how simple it is
it's already all perfect
and the more that you melt your world
down to the wind the more that you live
from that
place of non-duality the more that you
live from that place of child-like bliss
child-like peace childlike innocence
childlike joy wonder ah
and you're surrendered to that wind
again there's an effortless action
that's
channeling through
so that even these quote
sustainable development goals and new
planetary architectures
are coming through channeling through
effortlessly to be architected
for more abundance more prosperity more
flourishing more well-being
it's not to say we don't recognize that
duality and that dichotomy between
suffering and well-being
it's to say that there's a natural flow
from the non-dual wisdom
that channels through towards those
architectures
of what is more prosperous
and that's what's known as the middle
path that's what's known as the middle
way that's what's known as the
goldilocks zone as the tantric tradition
as sahaja samadhi
it's when you weave your profound
non-dual realizations
into the social fabric and that's just a
natural
occurrence an effortless action
once the diamond necklace is recognized
to be
already around the neck simply this
and it's not just the now it's not just
the now which is this happening
but it's all that's surrounding the now
how many components go into
that surrounding of the now
your now is enabled by the
photosynthesis
of the phytoplankton in the trees
because you're taking these twenty
thousand inhales a day
so there's this deep gratitude
to the planetary harmonic
interconnectedness and interdependence
and so there's that wisdom that comes
through to ensure that the ecological
frameworks of the planet are robust and
healthy anti-fragile
prosperous
what else is surrounding the now
there's the roof that's over your head
who built the roof that's over your head
the gratitude for those that built the
roof that's over your head
again formlessness appearing but the
gratitude
for it for the fireworks the food
that's in the fridge right now
what farmers grew the food
what people transited here for you to be
able to purchase it
what is surrounding the now
as you walk over to the fridge what is
the now
the now is your breaths
it is your ability to move your quote
physical form
that your body is in good enough of
shape to do so
the recognition as you open the fridge
that there is electricity that is coming
from the grid
that has been powering the refrigeration
all of that is surrounding the now
and that's just in the simplicity of the
home
similarly at an entire planetary level
like we described with photosynthesis
or like we described with geopolitics
like we described with the hundred
billion humans
that have lived and died lived and died
before today that have built
the infrastructures that enable
the now to be so
abundant and prosperous the fact that we
have these microphones these cameras
these computers these cell phones
this ability to disseminate this content
on this media platform
what is surrounding the now
take yourself into this deep time
perspective to
understand what is all surrounding the
now
to have more and more gratitude
more and more childlike bliss and awe
and wonder and peace and innocence
to just relax back
and recognize this
happening
simply this
and how it's being completely
missed due to these anchors
the anchor of time these four symbols
two zero two one
the anchor of languages
stay more silent and more
will be revealed to you
become more conscious of your breath as
well
and more will be revealed
the illusion of form and how quantum
mechanics reveals that all is
no thing all is energy
it is both that appearance the
formlessness appearing
as the illusion yet simultaneously
we have the beauty
of the fireworks to have that childlike
innocence wonder awe bliss and peace
to play
melt your world down to the wind
down to the wind
deep gratitude not just for the now
but all that's surrounding the now
all is already indescribably perfect
yet it remains for you to recognize it
at an experiential level
pierce the veil in the dream
and less and less will completely
miss this
the perfection of
this
thank you for tuning in
if you found the video valuable give it
a like
if you haven't yet subscribe let me know
how you feel in the comments below on
the video love to hear from you
share the video with people that you
feel
would be positively influenced by it and
i love you thank you
you